to patrice o'neill doc you watched it
dude we tried we couldn't
find it it's on comedy central comedy
central what not not
no it's not we tried it no no it's
probably on the app we don't have to
tell you how i've been watching it we
don't have the app
we didn't yeah no you it's free i
downloaded it it wasn't on our tv so we
didn't oh we tried finding it on youtube
it's not on youtube no it's not yeah she
watched it said it's good oh my god it
is yeah
i love you you know there's there's
there i don't think there could ever be
another person like him
he was just something different he was
so like his his biggest thing was just
being
honest he's like i have to be honest
yeah
yeah it kind of what's interesting about
that kind of hurt him too right because
like hollywood
he knew that and but like he also didn't
like didn't care yeah he didn't really
care because he
he was enjoying what uh you know he was
able to do that he goes
i don't know it's it's a it's really
good it's really good you know dude how
about if you go back chin
where you were before this it says burke
chrysler's machine stories might be
turned into a movie
where uh you i think you clicked on the
patrice thing
the youtube thing the youtube one
whatever you whatever the last thing
it's called that one right here yeah
maybe this one yeah
this one yeah see the machine story
being turned into a movie
what wow scroll down
fun fact anyone that might know burke
chrysler's life is a movie long story
short when the committee was in college
in the late 90s rolling stone magazine
story about crutch hard parting ways on
campus florida state naming the top part
a year
at the top party school in the country
straight coming to kick in the pants
you know he was going to tell this story
on stage and rogan told me he needs to
tell on stage
he was never telling the story and he
told the story on the podcast where he
was like you that should be a bit
why and then it happened yep uh
for another you all right dude he said
long story short
um the wrong story is the longest
[Laughter]
sheen came out okay add
all right russia rogan curtis should
tell a story on stage you're welcome for
that that's what i just told you
christchurch did
hone the story well by remote now it
looks like a machine store has some more
life in christchurch today
god he's squeezing everything out of the
story the legendary films
has optioned the rights to crash his
life once again this time developed
story into a feature film
christchurch dreamer will produce the
product which super early stage at the
moment
that's cool man damn we shouldn't let
that keep us from starting to cast the
film in our minds
that's big time man that's huge off a
bit he's
he's lost a lot of weight too huh no no
i think being fat is his brand right
no no having a shirt off he can't stop
drinking
christ sure lost a lot of weight i'm
sorry uh tom
lost a lot of weight a ton of weight
damn is that him
tom's lost a ton of weight look at him
top left one chin
damn that's not fake that's fake that's
super fake yeah oh
[ __ ] i was like girl yeah
handsome as [ __ ] in high school he was
uh he was training with uh bradley
martin
he would train there yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah he's zoo culture alumni but uh
anyways yeah that doc
like i think every comedian should watch
that you should watch that [ __ ] doc
it's good huh yeah it's it's j said it's
great
yeah tried to watch it man yeah you you
got it so yeah i
because i have that roku tv and i just
got the comedy center the tv was
yeah but we didn't have the app oh yeah
you gotta yeah you gotta like type in
their code
to download that app yeah i'll watch it
this week yeah i think you like it what
do you guys got for us chain cap
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song